at 12 o'clock we'll be announcing a plan
and it's a very big plan it will be a
suggestion between Israel and the
Palestinians
it's the closest it's ever come and
we'll see what happens we have the
support of the Prime Minister we have
the support of the other parties and we
think we will ultimately have the
support of the Palestinians but we're
going to see no party being an omen with
the head of the Laurita turducken
foreign-backed about a long subject Rami
Zambia CFCA the unequivocal kurata here
at do any and Latia Carla McCorkle
rotten Alicia Abner ultra listening back
tomorrow another and advance al-khalil
monitor alarm are allegedly set a
had he al mualim's Carla p.m. Raja in
the door and under clear of him wash
ability
you